your language is really important the
language that you speak not just to
other people but to yourself yourself
what's the reason that you're not doing
the thing that is difficult what's the
reason that you're not doing the thing
you want to do what's the reason you
want to be x you want to be doing why
what is that thing you want to do and
then what's the voice in your head what
comes back why are you not doing it
for a lot of people
it's either fear or it's hard
those are not acceptable reasons watch
your language if you're ever thinking
about an idea and the first thing that
comes back is
well it's hard okay great i do hard
things it's difficult yeah i do
difficult things
it's scary great you do scary things i'm
afraid awesome you do things you're
afraid of it starts to eliminate the
excuses you can come up with all these
reasons as to why you can't do it and
why the timing is not right now but if
you get underneath it what's the real
reason it's either because you're afraid
or because you think it's too difficult
and you need to attack those things